did you watch hikaru's predictions for
the im not a gm tournament oh i didn't
wait is it on youtube
i don't know if i'll watch the whole
thing
i just want to see what he says about me
all right it's almost time it's almost
time for the 2022 edition of the i am
not a gm speedchest championship you
have from right now up until the start
of the first match at 11 52 9am pacific
time
what's today today is
may 10th so it's too late um i can still
reveal what i chose for my bracket
picks don't wait too long or the
deadline might pass before you know
we'll be updating the standings right
here so check back early and often
predicted winner um in the in winner of
the eighth match james candy versus
kostya kavutski yeah so uh chuvalova is
a top seed
and uh like i think over 2700
blitzenbullet on chess.com so
i think that was a pretty
straightforward pick this one i think is
going to be one of the closest matches
in uh
the first round of the bracket
and i chose canty because kenji has been
like hardcore studying
and uh he recently had like an otb match
against danya in which daniel was super
impressed
so see what takara says
i i don't know who to predict here now
kasia is a much stronger player
objectively he is much better theory
much better fundamental understanding
but it is blitz it's it it is blitz it's
not um
it's not classical this is a very tough
one um
my guess is that it's really a toss-up
um but you know what it's somebody who's
always been basically uh
who someone who's not taken seriously
and slow chats and everyone assumes that
i'm just much better and rapid than in
class which is uh i have to sort of do
the same thing here and go with the
player i think it's better in blitz and
go with canty all right what
yeah so canty actually played levy in
the last imi gm
championship in the first round
and they had like a really close match
and canty was like super super well
prepared
i think he has a higher bullet rating
than kosher two so
both skills do come into play
predicted winner of the fourth match
between greg shahadi and lauren schreck
now one thing i want to say you guys and
this is not really controversial is that
it's very clear that chess.com uh they
found a way to tinker with the system to
make sure that all the first round
matches have some kind of hype to them
they did not base it purely the way that
it should have been um
i think that's true actually
i think in the past they've had some
formula of like blitz and bullet rating
but uh
yeah it might be one of the reasons why
me and levy are gonna maybe meet in the
the second round
the reason i say it is because greg
shahadi and lawrence trent i believe
they played in the final match of uh the
the i am not a gm maybe two years ago
or maybe i think it was like two years
ago i think they played in the final
match if i'm not mistaken
the number four in the number 13 seats
so um
so
yeah
who do i think is better in bull and if
i look at bullet and based on tricks i'm
going to give a very slight edge to
lauren so i'm going to go with lawrence
um that's just my guess
wow
yeah i think greg won like
by a decent margin the last time
but uh
anyway okay i'm going to skip ahead and
like to
when he
gets to me
vote for a levi so levi is going to win
that match uh he's correct next up we
have eric rosen versus tanya sachdev so
i'll say that tanya is
is kind of a mysterious opponent because
she doesn't play too much on chess.com
but she recently had like a really good
result in reykjavik like almost getting
a gm norm
she was on the top
like top five boards in the towards the
last round like over the board
yeah she's i think she's a better
classical player
but
i think it's safe to say i have a bit
more experience in online blitz and
bullet so
um but i think it's going to be a close
match because she she had a very close
match with levy
when they played
i think it was last year
so
[Music]
yeah let's see what hikaru says
um
tough match tough match i mean
very very tough match i'm gonna go with
eric and i'm simply gonna go with eric
because i feel like he's like more
experienced in these matches and i feel
like he'll be able to control his nerves
a little bit better in the time
scrambles than tanya will so i'll go
with eric so let's go to the
quarterfinals what do we have so because
he chose
me and levy he's going to have to choose
one of us
moving on to the semifinals
which of these players will advance the
semi-finals would it be nice if i
actually knew what the matches are
actually let me pull up with brac
because i can figure i can figure out
what the matches will be let me um oh
yeah this is a bra let me open this
image um
i'm going to just look at the actual
bracket here on my other monitor so
chuvalova versus canty i think shuvulov
is a clear favorite so i have to put
shuvalova okay so i have to put
shuvalova first because i think she's
gonna be canty um and then the other one
is lawrence versus cashlan skya
that's a very tough one um
so for this one i i i had it as um greg
and kashian sky are moving on i choose
kashlinskaya
i'm going to go lawrence making the
semifinals i'm going to go with lawrence
on that side and then on the other side
we have what yeah i had lauren's the
other side we have knocked down the
first round
plays danny i think bb sarah is gonna
gonna beat danny so i'll go with her and
the other one is gonna be levi against
eric rosen again like i said pretty
rigged on how we get that um very very
tough match there
i'm actually gonna i'm i'm gonna go out
on a limb and make predict the underdog
to win in that match
which one's the underdog
i thought we're both dogs of like
similar levels i'm gonna predict that
error is gonna win and the reason i'm
gonna predict what i don't know whether
to be offended or honored he thinks i'll
win but he also thinks i'm an underdog
what does that mean
that is because i'm gonna i'm gonna
assume that eric playing um playing over
the board in these tournaments is going
to um
wait we're both playing over the board
it's going to like make a difference
it's just going to be a little bit
sharper and build up enough of an
advantage before they get to the bullet
portion well now i feel i feel like
there's more expectations now
i kind of wish he picked levy so there'd
be less expectations
and less pressure
yeah i think levees played a few more
otv events than me
but maybe i played the more recent one
no levie recently played two so that's
good i'm gonna go with eric and
i'm just gonna base it off him actually
having played
so much pressure
having played and had i think better
results than levy did so i'll go with
that um for now
wait if caro picks me to move on
to the semi-finals in his bracket i'll
be up against bb sorry we have
semi-finals we have
on the other side we have bb sarah
versus uh eric rosen
uh
i'm going to predict that that's a very
tough match
i really don't know i think i'm going to
go with bb sarah and bb star wars lauren
in the final my
chances okay that makes me feel a little
bit better that there is
there's not so much expectation
now now it's my job to prove hikaru
wrong
and make it all the way to the final man
i think um
hopefully i don't prove him wrong by
losing to levy though that would be the
wrong way to prove him wrong
i think lawrence is going to win it i'm
going to predict that lawrence lawrence
wow uh
where is his name i'm going to predict
that lauren schwentz
i will say lawrence is a very like
sneaky and dangerous blitz player
and he works very hard in his game
but
i don't think he's going to make it past
greg
oh that's so interesting
anyway okay i think that's enough
reacting
uh i do encourage people to watch
the i am not a gm speech championship
matches will be taking place over the
coming
month
basically through june
like through mid-june there will be
matches
um i'll be playing tanya on may 24th
i don't think they've updated the site
but maybe what i'll do is i'll turn this
whole reaction thing into a youtube
video
and leave a link in the description
whole article all information
there's a nice prize fund a lot of
well-known players
and
thank you anna maya for the raid
appreciate that